yet another day of high drama at the
High Court it was the start of week 3 of
this libel trial between a Lister Johnny
Depp and the publisher of the Sun
newspaper but center stage was his
ex-wife
Amber Heard who for two weeks has
watched on as Depp and his friends have
given their version of events but today
it was her turn to tell her story in a
witness statement misheard recalled how
she feared for her life during their
marriage some incidents were so severe
that I was afraid he was going to kill
me either intentionally or just by
losing control and going too far he
explicitly threatened to kill me many
times especially later in our
relationship in it she accused Johnny
Depp of verbal and physical abuse
including screaming swearing punching
kicking head-butting and choking her as
well as extremely controlling an
intimidating behavior for the best part
of six hours Amber Heard was
cross-examined by Depp's lawyers she was
questioned about her use of drugs and
alcohol claiming it wasn't excessive as
she didn't use cocaine whilst with
Johnny Depp his lawyers say she is lying
Amber Heard told the court how the early
days of the relationship were the best
times
she said he could be intensely
affectionate warm and charming but she
claimed she was in a relationship with
two people she said she loved Johnny
Depp but was terrified of the monster
the court listen to a recording of an
argument between Depp and heard just
because I've thrown pots and pans does
not mean that you when asked if she
remembered the Rauh misheard replied
there were many of these and she only
threw objects to escape him Johnny Depp
has denied all allegations of assault
but the full 10 days of this trial so
far have been fueled with drama and very
dark details of what appeared to be a
toxic relationship and it's set to
continue Amber Heard will give evidence
for the next two days in what has been a
trial of the highest profile into Burma
she'd Sky News